Sophie I'm coming directly to you now
for for episode six what would you say
were your biggest burning questions for
the show Runners when you first read how
the birth sequence was gonna go because
there's there's a lot of moving parts
and and character development that I
didn't expect to get within that uh-huh
I think it was to try to like
um I mean it's it's it's such a there's
just so much going on in in the episode
it was like first of all just the
ramping up of like this her slowly dying
within giving birth like there's so many
scenes where she's just screaming but to
kind of like level it out so that it's
not all like one note throughout the
whole like birthing process
um and to kind of play with like her
being scared and her also just trying to
like survive and all of these um
elements and I was just
I was just really nervous the whole time
um I kind of just watched a bunch of
birthing scenes uh and and it was hard
for me because all the women that I've
talked to had such different birthing
experiences and I kind of wanted to try
to honor all of them
um and I think what just really helped
me out was just playing off of the other
girls like you just mentioned it was
like looking at their heart broken faces
and and you said it earlier so well like
we don't know what all the crew members
and and the cast members have been
through
um they have a level of sensitivity yeah
I'm just such an intense talk that was
also very important yeah all right I'll
build on that with a two two-part
question here what is something that you
need to do for yourself as a performer
in order to you know access that
headspace and prepare for a sequence
like that but then also what is
something that another cast member or
crew member did for you that made you
feel safe and able to go to a place like
that
um I'm not a very method so I don't like
like like Courtney gonna say we'll we'll
call cut and then I'll just gag and not
gag out like um
we'll call it and then I'll just sort of
laugh about a meme I was just like lay
back down and be like anyways
um about this meme that I sent you
earlier like I just um kind of get in
and out character pretty easily I do
need somewhat of a space like before the
scene where I'll just like put as often
like music or thinking about personal
things that make me cry
um and it's like I said earlier it's the
tiny little things like you um massaging
my feet like she would massage my feet
when I was like so tired by the end of
the day
um and it's just like this like physical
touch and like the nurturing side that
all the other cast members that whole
week really had towards me everyone like
before the day were like if you need
anything they would take me separately
and be like if you need anything today
if you need like to vent if you need to
chat like they just made me feel so
um at ease and and that I had people I
could go to event If Ever I felt the
need to because what you're not seeing
is that Sophie's also you know covered
in blood has somebody coming over
spraying her face 24 7 to like make it
all wet it's cold she's like shivering
like you know so I'm like we need a heat
pack
literally every second was like I got a
fresh I got a fresh new hot tea for you
in a second yeah just like making sure
that she's okay you know because it is
that was tough they're kicking me out of
here but because I'm in the business of
manifesting things I thought everyone
was great all the time you've been great
the entire time thank you
thank you
I don't know I I speak things into
existence when I believe in them no
matter no matter what happens no there's
going to be a lot of people that believe
that should happen I mean it thank you
guys for your time